un veterano ejecutivo petrolero elegido
para presidir la próxima Cumbre del
clima de las Naciones Unidas el sultán A
ver es director ejecutivo de la compañía
Nacional de petróleo de abu dhabi una
empresa que bombea unos 4 millones de
barriles de crudo al día el hecho de que
los emiratos árabes Unidos sean los
anfitriones de la cop28 alerta y
preocupa a los activistas
medioambientales al saber Lleva años
desempeñando lo que muchos consideran
roles contradictorios también es el
envío de los emiratos árabes para el
clima y defiende la necesidad de incluir
a los productores de petróleo en las
conversaciones
Si queremos pasar con éxito a la energía
del mañana no podemos simplemente
desconectarnos del sistema energético
actual no podemos simplemente apretar un
interruptor
Aunque al saber ha encabezado algunos
ambiciosos proyectos de energías
renovables emiratos árabes sigue siendo
una rica nación del Golfo con un pobre
historial medioambiental como era de
esperar el anuncio del jueves suscitó
críticas inmediatas el director
estrategia de política global de clima y
action Network International tuiteo el
nombramiento de altaber como presidente
de la Copa 28 es como mínimo
escandalosamente regresivo y
profundamente problemático y la ong
climática global witness reacciona de
forma contundente declarando no
invitarías a traficantes de armas a
dirigir conversaciones de paz Entonces
porque dejar que los ejecutivos del
petróleo dirijan las conversaciones
sobre el clima por su parte al saber
afirma que los emiratos árabes abordan
la cop28 con un gran sentido de la
responsabilidad y el mayor nivel de
ambición posible